soccer players need to ditch the
shinguards and start kicking field goals
well that's if you want an entire fan
base and coaching staff kissing the
ground you walk on EX soccer player and
now Cowboys kicker Brandon Aubrey was
put to the test yesterday with 59 and 60
yard attempts and he crushed them how
Aubrey even got into the NFL is a crazy
story he played D1 soccer at Notre Dame
then had a short stint in the MLS and
then got into software engineering for a
sec all until Aubrey and his wife were
watching an NFL game and they saw the
kicker Miss that's when his wife said
that he would probably make it if he was
the kicker that's supposedly when Aubrey
was like you know what yeah I probably
would have made it Aubrey began
practicing his kicks at night after his
day job he then got picked up by a usfl
team killed it and then got picked up by
the Dallas Cowboys